ladies and gentlemen the Anheuser-Busch
CEO has finally disavowed the Dylan
Mulvaney ad in private to investors
though he's not made a public statement
sales are down 26 percent they're going
to be giving out free cases of beer to
Distributors and they've vowed to spend
millions of dollars in marketing but uh
the boycott is particularly effective I
would say and there's videos now coming
out of people at sporting events where
the Bud Light is just behind the counter
totally full and everyone's buying other
brands so uh did Ian and Sheamus both
just leave at the same time yeah I don't
know where they went but they ran for
both leaves so uh so yeah uh let's let's
let's jump into this what are your
thoughts on the on the Budweiser thing
uh my thoughts are keep going you're
doing awesome all of you I I mean this
to every single person protesting Bud
Light yes I am so here for this
it's amazing
right on yeah yeah but but Budweiser
sucks and as a bush sucks it's a massive
multinational corporation there's super
anti-lgbtq plus so it's been beautiful
to see I love it oh they donate so much
to right-wing Republicans lgbtq laws so
Anheuser-Busch getting taken down oh man
I I'm so here for keeping me too
absolutely yeah uh they think that they
can pay off Republicans they can hire
GOP AIDS and that is going to be
satisfactory for their customers who are
upset with them as a brand so clearly
what we can see where I think we agree
is that Anheuser-Busch is a faceless
Corporation with no real values that is
willingness willing to spit in the faces
of the little guy if it earns him a
profit they're a trash company and
nobody should buy their products the
left and the right both agree here here
Unity for once I hope they fail same
thing with Disney keep going after
Disney absolutely take Disney down I'm
all for the right wing taking on Disney
all for the right wing taking on
Anheuser-Busch yes of course these are
terrible corporations I'm all
here for it
um by the way the Daily Mail is like the
number one source on the show right like
every single time you pulled it up
because that same site that you showed
me all sides media bias it has the Daily
Mail on right wing and I know that you
yourself
would be fantastic but if you use them
as a primary source you understand why
I'd say that like we don't use them as a
primary source okay what happens is when
we when we pull up stories
I'll I'll go to like CNN the New York
Times The Wall Street Journal Fox News
ABC and they'll each have like 300 words
and then you go to the Daily Mail after
doing a search on on key elements of the
story and the Daily Mail will have like
seven different versions of all breaking
down different components like if you
scroll down The Daily Mail they often do
these special sections where they have
entirely different stories within the
story providing more context like for
instance this story from the Daily Mail
not only talks about the current story
with the CEO but it even goes all the
way into all of the context going back
to the commercial that was was released
the the sale drop at six percent in the
first week to the video it like covers
literally every even as a photo of the
VP and her husband how in-depth this
story is so it's like if I'm gonna pull
up a single article I can pull up five
ABC CBS New York Times or I can just
pull this one that has seemingly
everything including Kid Rock including
John Rich including Bud Light being
poured into a dumpster it's a massive
aggregate later yeah but honestly I have
no problem with y'all going after uh
Bud Light not have a time go
nuts um I have a really big problem with
what I feel on this show is a lot of
anti-trans Hysteria and fear-mongering
that takes place and open that book uh I
have that book at home we can talk about
that in a second and I'm totally
comfortable talking about that book I've
read it
um should it be in schools I want to
talk to you about the trans issue though
because that's great that's why I asked
about the book okay we can get to the
books in the schools the curriculums and
everything that the Florida's taken away
but you are you profess to be kind of
like fact based science-based right yeah
like you pull up I've noticed you want
to pull up stats and figures and stuff
like that of course why is it that you
push propaganda when it comes to trans
people like what that is so far beyond
the pale like what okay let's start with
gender affirming care gender affirming
care you're very very against I've heard
you call it utilize it the utilize like
population I don't call mutilation I've
never said that that's what you say on
your shirt I don't know if he does I
call it I know children I call it child
sex change
when you were talking about Dwyane Wade
moving his family someone in the crowd
said why are you mutilating your son
that was a quote from someone else I
didn't say that I call it but then I've
explicitly said I don't take the right
agitator approach of calling it
mutilation because that's not effective
in having a conversation I will plainly
call it a child sex change as what it is
I'm not going to call it gender
affirming or mutilation because I don't
think those things accurate accurately
explain what it is okay so when it comes
to gender affirming care zero two about
talking about child sex change no I'm
talking about gender zero two about ten
years the answer is yes you got to
Define it okay because if you're talking
about something different tell us what
you're talking about all right so if
someone is trans and they are young and
until they're about 10 years old before
they go through puberty gender affirming
care would be in the form of you using
different pronouns preferred pronouns
and allowing them to dress differently
yeah I don't care about that do you have
a problem with that here yes I do I
don't I don't okay so both of you don't
right okay so do you accept that there
is no surgery being performed on
children at that age from 0 to about 10
there's nothing there's no hormone
blockers there's no Purity there is
hormone blockers I don't think surgery
is happening okay so armor under 12. so
hormone blockers aren't given to
Children until they go through puberty
that's not true we actually pull this up
with Destiny he actually he actually
called that I was wrong about a stat
okay what we found was 47
um cross-sex hormones I think it was
something like 17 000 puberty blockers
and like 2 000 double mastectomies for
girls after the age of uh of 13 or
whatever but uh so it doesn't apply to
anything I just said puberty blockers
were pre-teen uh puberty blockers yes
because they have to give them the
people before puberty starts of course
right so so you okay so you're just
referring what I just said from zero to
ten till about you're about to go
through puberty gender affirming care
only comes in the form of using
different pronouns using different names
allowing them to dress differently and
that's it and you don't have a problem
with that boy Looper on two okay so
we'll get to Lupron but up to that point
you don't have a problem with any of
this yet right I'm saying and you agree
that there is no surgery being performed
on children at that age
let me just start from beginning so I
can make sure I'm getting what you're
saying right yeah I don't care if
parents call their kids names or
whatever I I care about medical or
surgical intervention okay so that
doesn't happen until about the age of
about 16. that's the average age four
that's that's act but but you're wrong
okay like and and look we had Destiny on
the show we went to great detail about
it there are girls who are 13 who are
getting this done and there was a study
actually it was Canadian I believe 12 to
17. they had several hundred surgeries
performed okay so again I said I said
the average age but if you want to say
that there are people who get this at 12
that could be the case who would have it
I think let's start with puberty
blockers Tim Lupron you both have a big
problem with Lupron I don't know a lot
about it but I consider it a medical
treatment yeah yeah we shouldn't be uh
giving Lupron to kids so you don't think
you should give the Uber on the kids why
why don't you want Lupron be given to
trans kids to because it's it a puberty
blocker that inhibits the natural
function and development of their body
and more importantly I think think my
view is built upon what we've seen out
of Europe already right so earlier on
maybe a few years ago I was more
agnostic on the issue until Sweden
Denmark Finland abandoned this and the
Tavistock Center got shut down and the
data they released said this actually
caused more harm than good and then I
was like well okay hey how about that
and for some reason United States
they're still hell-bent on moving
forward with what we can already see
from you know better countries with
Better Health Care Systems saying no to
this right okay so I can address those
individually because I have the
explanation as to why that happened when
it comes to Lupron 0 to 10 is about the
age where gender affirming care only
comes in the form of different names
pronouns stuff like that we can all
agree that's completely fine
I don't fine okay fine but it's their
show so I just want to comments my
position is more just like I don't man
like social therapy stuff uh they say
that after puberty desistance rates are
between 60 65 and like 92 percent so
that's completely false I I I'll get to
that
10 10 follow-up studies found existence
of 61 to 98 yeah can you can you click
on the Wikipedia article
de-transition topics oh you're missing
the mic can't hear you oh sorry what are
the studies what are we talking about I
would like to know if you were taking
these studies specific well because I
have each one of them written down here
and I'm quite curious is the Drummond
study one of them is the Wallen study
estenzma the Swedish study a part of
this the 2011 study probably I don't
know well we should know this is
incredibly important for me it's not
this is 2018. this is uh gender
dysphorian adolescence current
perspectives in the National Library of
Medicine okay scroll down to the
conclusion of this one I get the mic
again oh so you can carry it around yeah
yeah move it I gotta get gotta get used
to this yeah dog
I know scroll down to the conclusion of
the study oh yeah I mean I want to at
least skim some of the what the numbers
in reference are to like the reference
while you're skimming I when I think of
a little key
like disorders I'm a girl the parent I I
would hope that the parent would be like
you can be you you can pretend to be
whatever you want you can be an actor
you can play a girl but I get afraid
when a mom's like he said he's a girl
that means he's trans right so for this
it's not a process it doesn't exist in
which someone can say hey I'm a boy I'm
a girl and then they go into a doctor's
office and like well take some Lupron
it's you do you do years and years of
consultation between doctor and and
between like a therapist and between the
patients itself I'm just going to read
this sure of course adolescence is a
crucial time for identity and
psychosexual development in young people
with gender identity concerns the
outcomes of GDC have been discussed in
terms with its pers of its persistence
and desistence for most children with
GDC whether GD will persist or desist
will probably be determined between the
ages of 10 and 13 years although some
may need more time evidence from the 10
available perspective follow-ups studies
from childhood to adolescence reviewed
in the study by restori and Steensma
indicate that for around I was right I
asked if this was okay 80 of children
who meet the criteria for GDC right but
you said you said 2011. oh so there's
multiple scenes uh steen's studies
they've actually built upon each other
and the problem with the students must
study unfortunately is that they
actually characterized people who were
not Trans in that study they didn't
compare people who were trans to people
who were trans and then he transitioned
they compared people in the general
population
for that the actual author of the study
has come out since and said that what
kind of said that the study what can I
pull up to confirm that okay like
because look I pulled up a study that
said a thing you've made a counterclaim
I'll love I will pull it up no no
absolutely yeah okay so go to because I
don't know who esteem is okay so well
Stephen's about and the problem I'll say
one more thing is I had this written
down 45.3 of the people did not reapply
for treatment they counted that as
people who were detransitioning when
they weren't in fact doing that
um
we're literally talking about resistance
right if they're including people who
desisted you'd have to get the numbers
they included people who did not reapply
for treatment they counted that as
someone who was desisting that's just
someone who didn't show up against
that's that's the you do not literal
not whatsoever Tim that is someone who
has decided they just don't want to go
talk to that doctor or experience things
with that doctor they could have gone
off to a different doctor they could
have done something else but that is not
someone who has verifiably said I was
trans I'm no longer trans that's just
people who did not show up your thing
okay so go to transadvocate.com I'm not
going to uh I need a study or something
not an advocacy website okay I pulled up
a scientific study for you I'm not
pulling up a non-profit job so this is
an interview with the person who did the
study in this article I have pulled up a
scientific study for you and you're the
person who did and I'm challenging you
with the person who did the
study and they're telling me to pull up
an advocacy right website which is not
on par with a scientific study thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time